vorrei qualche modo proporre una sfida
cioè quella di qualche modo per salirvi
della praticità dell'infinito è una
bella sfida perché l'infinito sembra in
qualche modo la cosa meno pratica che
possa esistere cosa meno maneggevole
la cosa meno
concepibile in maniera chiara mi basta
pensare ad esempi classici di infiniti
tratti naturalmente dalla matematica i
numeri naturali la serie dei numeri
naturali
i punti di una retta
la nozione di eternità
per ciascuno di queste di questi esempi
possiamo pensare a i numeri naturali
come una serie che continua
indefinitamente una volta che un numero
naturale io posso produrre un altro
posso calcolare qualche modo del
successore di quello vero naturale una
volta che abbia dei punti sulla retta
che posso trovare altri ma altra cosa
cosa ben più difficile è immaginare
tutti i numeri naturali come un'entità
in qualche modo esistente reale più
difficile immaginare tutti i punti di
una retta
più difficile è immaginare
l'eternità cioè il tempo che si estende
definitamente in entrambe le direzioni
ecco perché l'infinito in qualche modo
sembra poco pratico se non addirittura
inconcepibile
aristotele
ha fissato questa impossibilità a
qualche modo dell'infinito questa
mancanza di praticità dell'infinito o
come dire difficoltà a
immaginare l'infinito
attraverso questa dottrina per cui che
discute nel libro terzo della sua fisica
per cui l'infinito esiste solo impotenza
ripensiamo agli esempi che ho fatto
precedentemente io posso contare le
posso continuare a contare
indefinitamente ma non posso mai vedere
in qualche modo avere conoscenza di
tutti i numeri posso continuare se ho
una c'è una retta se una linea posso
continuare magari a suddividerla trovare
altri punti ma
ecco continuare ci dà l'idea di una
potenzialità di qualcosa che può essere
continuato appunto a piacere mai di
un'attualità di qualcosa che è dato in
una maniera come dire reale autonoma
sussistente e questa concezione di
aristotele questa idea di aristotele ha
dominato in qualche modo le dottrine
delle concezioni dell'infinito come
altre concezioni di aristotele hanno
dominato in qualche modo lo sviluppo del
pensiero filosofico
nei secoli successivi e non sono state
messe in dubbio per molti secoli non
sono state contestate
c'è un signore
me molto caro forse qualcuno di voi avrà
riconosciuto
valore spinosa
filosofo che molti secoli dopo la figura
fondamentale per il canone di sanno
della filosofia occidentale
nel xvii secolo elabora una concezione
che qualche modo
ribalta e non maniera radicale
l'idea aristotelica per cui l'infinito
si possa dare solo impotenze
a spinosa non dice soltanto questo
spinosa concepire l'eresia più grande
dal punto di vista della religione della
storia delle religioni che si possa
immaginare
dio ap corpo dio è materia dio
e l'universo stesso l'universo fisico
dio
ancora più difficile qualche modo da
comprendere e l'unica sostanza che
esiste
non perché tutte le altre cose non
esistano ma perché tutte le altre cose
sono manifestazioni in qualche modo di
quest unica sostanza l'unica entità
realmente sussistente ed è autonoma e
dio e anche gli esseri umani anche i
singoli individui non sono altro che
manifestazioni non sono sostanze non
esistono in maniera autonoma ma solo
manifestazione di quest unica sostanza
che dio e cos'è dio è la sostanza che
consta di infiniti attributi infiniti
attributi fra cui la materia e
l'intelletto e il pensiero di o in
materia ma non è solo materia e anche
pensiero ma noi conosciamo soltanto due
attributi di dio perché in realtà gli
attributi di dio sono infiniti ciascuno
dei quali
spinosa esprimono estesa ed emma è
infinita
e fin qui siamo alla metafisica
alla teologia
ma poi
cosa produce questa nuova concezione che
mette al centro l'infinito la
pensabilità la concedibilità
dell'infinita
bene nel momento in cui l'essere umano
si rende conto capisce di essere una
manifestazione di una sostanza infinita
eterna
ecco che coglie quella che la sua vera
essenza la sua vera natura
accede a quella che è la libertà
che la caratteristica stessa dell'uomo
che l'uomo concepisce soltanto quando si
identifica le liquidità di dio
nell'infinita della mente eterna di dio
ma in questa identificazione con dio
l'essere umano non è una mera non
concepisce soltanto l'identificazione
per così dire metafisica ma
un'identificazione che lo porta ad
essere in qualche modo infinitamente
attivo capace di trasformare il mondo la
realtà
ecco perché spinoso il quinto libro
della sua etica suggella questa
concezione che mette al centro dio
la sostanza infinita dicendoci che
quando più ciascuna cosa è perfetta e
tanto più è attiva e tantomeno passiva
al contrario quanto più attiva tanto più
è perfetta
e a chi si sta riferendo si sta
riferendo l'uomo all'uomo che ha
un'attività infinita nel momento in cui
si concepire a questa capacità di essere
infinitamente attivo quando si
concepisce nella maniera corretta cioè
come manifestazione di questa infinita
divina
è talmente attivo l'uomo è talmente
capace di trasformare la realtà che
alcuni filosofi hanno pensato che al
cuore della concezione spinoziana ci sia
l'idea
un'idea fondamentalmente politica ecco
perché spinosa
l'effetto fondamentale pratico di questa
concezione che mette al centro
l'infinito e l'infinita potenza di dio è
in qualche modo anche dell'uomo cioè la
capacità e qualche modo di trasformare
la società della realtà
che si produce attraverso quasi una
sorta di per sé è
sovversione alcuni filosofi questo
volume che vedete nell'immagine hanno
parlato in fatto di mons d1 spinosa
sovversivo interpretando questa dottrina
nella sua del suo elemento più pratico
cioè quello della trasformazione della
realtà
qui abbiamo un pochino genere però tutto
si tocca lo vedremo
questa persona forse non la riconoscete
pochi voi promette la conoscono
mistico visionario teologo ma in realtà
di mestiere un matematico ed è un canto
matematico tedesco che alla fine
dell'ottocento rivoluzione qualche modo
il pensiero matematico
perché
perché sostiene una cosa che spinosa
aveva già anticipato in qualche modo
filosoficamente maniera puramente
filosofica e secoli precedenti
che lui qualche modo pone come base
della sua teoria della sua concezione
dell'infinito solo l'infinito
attuale
cosa significa attuale sembra difficile
ma realtà abbiamo detto che aristotele
pensava che l'infinito fosse solo
potenziale cioè non desse luogo a delle
entità determinate
non esiste
l'insieme di tutti i numeri naturali io
posso solo continua raccontare
indefinitamente e canto risponde ad
aristotele in qualche modo seguendo
spinosa no soltanto l'infinito attuale
cioè l'infinito di una cosa come
l'insieme di tutti i numeri naturali e
reale ecco che
il paradigma aristotelico viene
ribaltato anche dal punto di vista
matematico
non solo cattolici segna in qualche modo
a pensare a contare
verso l'infinito e anche oltre rifiuta
in beta crea possiamo dire dei numeri
dei numeri infiniti infiniti numeri
infiniti
come fa
un suggerimento viene proprio
dall'immagine che stai questa
diapositiva sembra difficile ma realtà
se seguiamo la spirale che vedete nella
diapositiva possiamo cominciare a
contare con i numeri naturali e poi ad
un certo punto questi numeri naturali
qual modo si polverizzano convergono
verso questo primo numero infinito che
si chiama omega e poi possiamo
continuare questo processo possiamo
continuare a contare dopo mega con la
mega più uno e lo più due ma possiamo
applicare tutte le ordinarie operazioni
aritmetiche algebriche e produrre nuovi
numeri abbiamo infiniti nuovi numeri
infiniti non solo
cantor di bost che quando mettiamo
insieme questi nuovi numeri infiniti
produciamo altri numeri infiniti per cui
ci sono ordini di infinito diverso
anche questo sembra un'eresia eresia più
grande di quella certo senso di quella
speranza ma ci sono ordine infinito
diversa ma com'è possibile
definito sembra unico come si fa a
concepire un infinito diverso dall'altro
infinito si può fare
si può fare con la teoria di canta
z fc acronimo
è una teoria importante materia
fondamentale
perché
perché è grazie a un concetto molto
semplice concetto che pervade la
matematica che costituiti perché che
costituisce in qualche modo una lezione
fondamentale matematica quello di
insieme che noi possiamo concepire
questo infinito attuale di canto
di cosa parla zf ci
parla dell'universo dove ci sono i
numeri di cantor ma ci sono anche tutte
le entità matematiche
pensate alla semplicità all'eleganza e
alla bellezza di questo universo
dell'universo in questa teoria ad ogni
livello ad ogni linea orizzontale che
poi vedete in questo colon o vigilato
che l'universo si producono nuove entità
matematiche tutte le dita matematiche
tradotte nel linguaggio degli insiemi
stanno lì dentro
solo costruendo questa figura
trombette non ho riportato i dettagli
precisi della della costruzione
dell'universo però solo diciamo provate
a immaginare come questa figure qualche
modo nei vari livelli di questa dura
progressivamente si possano si generano
in qualche modo tutte le entità
matematiche
l'universo però
c'è una piccola complicazione
l'universo in realtà e questo è un
risultato che piacere più recente ed è
un risultato la scoperta
una concezione
a cui io ho dato come filotto matematica
come studioso come logico
contributo è l'idea che l'universo in
realtà se lo guardiamo bene
non è una realtà è un multiverso
coltivazione parola di cui si sente
parlare molto spesso
questo multiverso insiemistica e realtà
va come un collasso una sovrapposizione
di universi diversi
allora l'idea è che noi vediamo sigo
l'universo fino a che non scomponiamo
questo universo in una serie di immagini
diverse diverse
in cui ci sono universi diversi
di quella teoria di cui abbiamo parlato
prima di zf jane cosa significa questo
perché è importante perché interessante
questa cosa
interessante perché ci sono delle verità
matematiche
che possono cambiare seconda
dell'universo in cui noi ci troviamo
c'è una parte di questo punti verso che
è comune a tutti i tour i versi di cui
noi possiamo parlare ma c'è una parte
che cambia
e quindi a seconda dell'universo in cui
noi ci troviamo
vedremo in qualche modo le verità
matematica in una maniera leggermente
pensate alle varie geometrie
la geometria non euclidea
esempio che si fa molto spesso geometrie
in cui basta cambiare basta non accetta
postulato delle parallele per avere un
universo giuseppe ricomposto diverso
ecco la stessa cosa accade con
l'infinito e con la teoria di serie ma
c'è una differenza che con l'infinito e
con l'udeur e degli insiemi codifichiamo
tutta quanta la matematica quindi questo
ep generale
e qualcosa qualche modo
più universali e grado di incorporare
inglobare corcovado tutto il discorso
matematico
una cosa che
forse con cui lo avremmo che fa a breve
che sconvolgerà qualche modo la nostra
tecnologia nostre vite sappiamo perché
se ne parla o le tensioni continue
quantistici che avranno delle capacità
di calcolo che i computer attuali
computer quantistici si basano sull'idea
che noi possiamo avere unità minime
l'informazione che li chiamiamo bit e
nel caso moltissimi musica
e qualche modo sono in grado di mettere
insieme
prima
prima di effettuare la misurazione dello
stato reale dello stato reale
quantistico in teoria
questa unità aviv informazione contiene
un numero infinito di stati possibili
conto il beat tradizionale che invece
può avere solo questa
prima della misurazione perché la
misurazione poi porta un collasso
infiniti strati in queste arti del
bene abbiamo visto alcune applicazioni
fantasmagoriche certo senso per certi
versi
scientifico matematico di un'intuizione
pieno stile molto semplice c'è
un'infinità esiste
è reale
non è semplicemente un processo
beh troviamo poi la questione della
praticità e qui concludiamo
con un filosofo
che in qualche modo è per il tipo di
stupire con 12 abbastanza distante
a questioni matematiche che però ha
voluto anche entrare
in questioni di questo tipo alle pagine
fino ad ora c'è
che ha formulato suo libro importante
non essere l'evento una questione del
soggetto
che in qualche modo è modellata in
questo concerto
vi ricordate la teoria aziende precisa
la caotica
e dice il soggetto come un modello di
questa terra che cos'è un modello ancora
una volta è un insieme di oggetti che
corre su e si comporta queste genti si
comportano esattamente come vogliono in
azione
il soggetto è una sorta di modello di
queste ferite ma perché come un modello
che questa cosa centra la teoria degli
insiemi cosa c'è tra questo infinito che
è formalizzato davvero del singolo
soggetto
bene questi modelli che esiste un modo
di costruire i modelli di questa teoria
ma metri per costruire che si chiama
forza
cosa fare forse fi po che io avrei un
modello testate nina e in qualche modo
lo allarga lo spazio ci metto anche
oggetti ma come faccio
morso questo modello si fosse lo
costringo a dirci un modello che altro
certo livello di determinatezza
costringo questo modello a darci
ulteriori informazioni ad allargarsi ad
espandersi
ecco il soggetto secondo maggio secondo
cioè l'individuo la soggettività umana
all'infinita che a questo modello di
sette fc
ma anche indeterminatezza di queste ore
di questi modelli che poi quando sono e
spazi sono allargati quando sono
fortunati ci danno come dire ulteriori
informazioni cos'è che forza di forza
l'esperienza concreta della realtà
riservato il soggetto
è il militante della verità
è soggetto politico il certo tipo
pratico che incide sulla realtà sulla
storia
la società
è il soggetto e militante della vita che
lavorano solo per l'emancipazione
dell'umanità e anche la lista creatore
scienziato la mattek e diverte un mondo
incantato le esperienze
le esperienze che forza di ciò che il
soggetto a diventare qualcosa di più
ampio
si possono vedere come questi modelli
infiniti che sono partiti da una parte
degli indeterminato non siamo
determinanti che però si localizzano
quello che quando chiede 20 si chiama
esperienze offerte ed ecco che riappare
in qualche modo l'idea ancora una volta
di poter essere dei soggetti che
trasformano
portare soggetti anche sovversivi dei
soggetti rivoluzionari perché in qualche
modo alla base questa idea
del soggetto cioè quelli freddi
percorso tra cui storia perché
allora la cosa che compete con questo vi
lascio e della cosa da cui io sono
partito qualche modo per
preparare questo io per te una frase di
legge dice una lettera non solo letta
dice il lavoro teoretico lavoro della
filosofia dei concetti di concetti che
sempre più difficili ma realtà sono
semplici sono intuizioni semplici e
fondamentali
me ne vado convincendo ha bisogno di più
produce del fuoco più che non è pratico
di quel quel lavoro teorico è più
pratico del pratico una volta
rivoluzionato e avete della
rappresentazione della realtà
vi lascio un po
[Applauso]